all right so yesterday after the big
biden putin summit former president
donald trump appeared on sean hannity's
fox news program to deliver i guess what
was billed as
analysis of joe biden's meeting with the
russian president vladimir putin that
we talked about earlier it took place in
geneva switzerland and it was
really pathetic and in some sense it was
almost kind of sad
a trump desperate for relevance
relegated to opining about
how the guy who defeated him easily did
during a summit with a guy vladimir
putin
who walked all over donald trump during
trump's presidency now
whoa hold on a second everybody take it
easy i'm not saying trump and putin
ever got together to plan anything i'm
not saying i want a war with russia
i don't i just i've got to be clear
because otherwise that
sort of putin-loving segment of the
audience
will come after me but let's check out
some of these clips
and trump is just so jealous of joe
biden
and the fact that biden just kind of
behaved normally during the summit like
the summit was no big
success other than it was a normal
summit
and it was a return to kind of standard
diplomacy and the interview with hannity
very quickly went completely
off the rails uh trump now just this
isn't even related to putin
trump just doing openly anti-vaxxed
talking points now listen to this
now we have to get back and the schools
have to get open and frankly uh
we're lucky we have the vaccine but the
vaccine on very young people is
something that you gotta really stop you
have to get back
to running your country i mean what is
he talking about
schools basically are open and it's also
summer for
some school districts already and
everybody's going to be back in the fall
most schools already opened and vaccines
on young people
we have to stop vaccines on young people
we haven't even started vaccines on
young people
pfizer is approved for 12 plus otherwise
there's nothing else we're starting to
test the vaccine now
we're testing it safely it appears to be
very safe
these are just straight-up anti-vax
talking points now from trump
who by the way wants credit for the
vaccine which is really dangerous for
children
even though there's not actually
evidence of that see reasons
and i am a big believer in what we did
with the vex
it's incredible what we did trump is the
winner for doing the vaccine
but it's a very dangerous one for
children and we've got to stop giving it
to them
which we're not yet until it's tested
and appears safe
you see the results but to have every
school
child where it's 99.99
they just don't you know they're just
not affected or affected badly
having to receive a vaccine i think is
something that you should
of course nobody has to receive it
unless you
eventually if it becomes a requirement
to go to school
as has been the case for other vaccines
the parents would get to choose
i want my kid in this school and so i
will do the required vaccinations
to attend of which if covet 19 is added
would not be the only vaccine or you can
opt not to go there but nobody is being
forced to vaccinate
we don't have to stop vaccines on kids
because we haven't even started them yet
it's
it's all wild in this next clip hannity
cuts trump off
when he starts a completely unhinged
rant about
wind turbines again they're making
windmills all over the place to ruin our
land and kill our birds
to kill everything windmills are killing
everything guys
the the windmills that they're killing
everything not going to be and they're
very intermittent
as you learn from watching uh over the
last four months it's intermittent
energy
it's not good it's not going to power
our great factories
and it's real what did you make yeah
there was a question of what there was a
question of whether ukraine would join
nato and biden's answer oh man that is
just great hannity's like this is not
the the windmills killing everybody is
not a great direction to go in for
hannity's program so hannity tries to
derail that
then trump is still calling the 1918
flew the 1917 fleet
and if we weren't successful sean i'll
tell you this you would have another
1917
uh tragedy where almost 100 million
people died
yep still calling it that still calling
it the 1917 flu
uh trump then in the midst of this uh
wanting to go back to talk about hillary
and hannity is actually helping him do
it take a look at this we know that
hillary clinton paid for the dirty
russian misinformation dossier
that even christopher steele doesn't
stand by and
the sub source doesn't stand by right
and then it wasn't just hannity doing it
a trump also
insisting on going back and talking
about
comey and mccabe and they they just will
not stop
and i'm talking about very very serious
things if you look at comey and mccabe
and the two lovers and all of the things
that went on
and they weren't prosecuted if you read
the horowitz report
and of course everyone's still waiting
for durham what happened to durham
how is that allowed to go into another
administration by the way is he in the
witness protection program
i'd like to know where he is too is he
in the witness protection program
really touching on the issues of the
dave remember trump invited on to
analyze as if trump could analyze
anything trump invited on to analyze
the uh putin biden summit
and doing anti-vaxx doing the 1917
flu doing what about peter strzok and
his lover
uh paige or whatever her name was uh
trump then
again completely delusional claiming
that an endorsement from him
is stronger than anything else anybody
could ever
even imagine so i'm very honored to say
that my endorsement means more
than any endorsement that has ever been
given by anybody i mean
you know i don't know exactly what he's
talking about trump
uh became president republicans then
lost the house
in 2018 lost the senate in 2020
and lost the white house in 2020 and
trump wants us to believe his
endorsements are really really strong
of course no trump interview is complete
until he again sort of references i
didn't really lose and i may be back
soon
here he is doing that you ever
considered it and are you considering it
well i am and frankly if you think of it
that's what i've been doing and talking
about for
a long time and i guess that's why we
got him by surprise in 16
and in 20 we did much better than we did
in 16 and
uh shockingly we were supposed to win
easily at 64 million votes and we got 75
million votes and
we didn't win but let's see what happens
on that the whole thing is
let's see because trump could be back
absolutely any day
and still still sort of floating that
and signaling his followers
and then lastly here um hannity throws a
complete softball to trump about
if you run in 2024 what will you do
differently and trump just he can't keep
it together he talks about the clintons
and fake investigations and all sorts of
wacky stuff
is there anything and we have a minute
left
if you do run in 2024 right what might
you do differently what do you know now
that you didn't know in 2016
well you know we ran a very successful
administration we had the greatest
economy in history we had 160 million
jobs we were never even close to that no
nobody was ever even close to that and
we did it twice because then we did it
after the pandemic we came with a
vaccine we did a lot of great things
and we did it after but i was under
siege with
fake investigations and everything and i
was doing this while i was under
siege from phony people with phony
russia russia russia that was caused by
the people were fake
that's that's interesting we've known he
thinks the investigations were fake but
the people doing them were fake too
clinton and the dnc democrats and
all of that and we did it we built space
force we did you know we did
we rebuilt the military we got the
largest tax cut in history the largest
regulation cuts in history
i'm pretty sure everything he's saying
is a lie
they weren't the biggest tax cuts in
history he did cut some regulations but
it
unfortunately he didn't cut that many
but not they were damaging the cuts but
i don't think anything he's saying here
is true nothing
none of it plus we did anwar which
they've already
excluded thanks to murkowski in alaska
and uh you know hannity rapping yeah so
i mean just an incredible
incredible bizarre interview and my
question continues to be
can anybody tell me specifically what
was the massive failure of the biden
europe trip that every right winger is
ranting about they say it was a failure
but they don't mention what the failure
was
they don't have anything specific to
mention they just want to create this
atmosphere that it was terrible
and then the fox viewers just repeat it
but
they never can explain what was the
failure and also
don't forget what happened in the putin
trump summit in helsinki
in july of 2018 where the the whole
question was is trump going to confront
putin
about russia's meddling in the 2016
election
and trump came out and when he was asked
about it said i hold
both countries responsible partially
blaming the u.s
if there was russian meddling which he
won't say there was
it's partially the us's fault and then
he also said listen putin denied it
putin denied it and he seemed sincere in
his denial so
everybody just runs around trump trump
met with kim jong-un and he thought he
got incredible concessions from kim
jong-un
didn't realize these are the concessions
that they always make and never stick to
trump thought it was a big victory
trump meets with putin and he says i
don't know putin he was pretty
convincing and it's like this is what
putin does this
putin is the slick guy trump wishes he
could be and
trump fell for that and it's just all
humiliating and embarrassing and joe
biden's not perfect or anything close to
it
but it is good to be beyond the insanity
of foreign policy under trump if you've
been watching the show you've probably
heard me talk about how much
i love my helix mattress well i was
really excited to hear that helix has
launched a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's solidly built it's
huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it
and the best part is everything comes
with a lifetime warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get
20 off your entire order when you get
there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video